قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا
قرب بلده سلواد شرقي مدينه رام الله بضفه
الغربيه وقالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان
احمد كحلاء استشهد بعد اصابته برصاصه في
عنقه وافادت مصادر اعلاميه اسرائيليه نقلا
عن الامن الاسرائيلي بان قوه الاسرائيليه
اطلقت النار على الشهيد بذاريعه محاولته
تنفيذ عمليه الطعن على جنودها بينما نفى
شهود وعيال الروايه الاسرائيليه
كما اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ثمانيه فلسطينيين على الاقل بينهم اسرع
محررون من مناطق متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه
والقدس المحتله وقالت مؤسسه تعنى بشؤون
الاسرى ان عمليات الاعتقال تركزت في مدن
رام الله والخليل وجنين والقدس
معنا من رام الله مراسيل الجزيره سمير ابو
شماله سمير اذن شهيد اخر ايضا يلحق بقافله
الشهداء في الايام الماضيه وايضا دائما
نفس الروايه الاسرائيليه بانه كان ينوي
طعنه جندي الاسرائيلي
الذين سقطوا برصاص جيش الاحتلال الصلي
سبعه من هؤلاء الشهداء وهم من محافظه جنين
وايضا ثلاثه من الشهداء هم من الاطفال
الروايه الايطاليه هي دائما تقول بان هناك
زعم او بذريعه
الوجود محاوله لتنفيذ عمليه طعن بحق جنود
قوات الاحتلال الصليب ولكن ما جرى هذا
الصباح بحسب شهود العنايه حيث تحدثنا مع
احدهم وقال لنا بان هناك همم كان الشهيد
احمد البالغ من العمر 45 عاما
برفقه ابنه في مركبته الخاصه تحت الجسر
المؤدي الى بلده سلواد شرقيه مدينه رام
الله حيث كان هناك حاجز عسكري مفاجئ في
تلك المنطقه وكان هناك ازدحام بالمركبات
بجراء هذه الاجراءات التعسفيه من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه ومن ثم كان هناك همم
اطلاق ابواقي السيارات للاحتجاج على هذا
الحجز العسكري ولكن الجيش الاحتلال قد
اطلق قنابل او ربما قنابل صوتيه على همم
المواطنين حيث اصطدمت احدى القنابل بمركبه
الشهيد والذي خرج وترجل من سيارته همم
باقي يصيح على جنود الاحتلال لماذا
استهددته سيارته ولكن اعتدوا عليه بالضرب
بشكل رشه بغاز الفلفل هو من تم اطلاق
النار عليه بشكل من مسافه صفر وقد اصيب
برصاصه في العنق وسوف وفقا لبيان وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه نجحته اقعديني على
استشهاده متاثرا بجروحه في مجمع فلسطين
الطبي وايضا كان هناك احتجاج
لابنه البالغ من العمر 17 عاما وبعد رشه
ايضا بغاز الفلفل من تم الافراج عنه ونقله
الى مستشفى طبيه الى لتلقي العلاج على
مستوى وهذا يذكرنا بما جرى في استهداف
وقتل الشاب عمار مفلح في حواره مطلع الشهر
الماضي عندما ااه اجهز عليه احد جنود
الاحتلال من مسافه السفر بعد مشاهده
الجيش الاحتلال هو معه الضوء الاخضر
لاطلاق النار على الفلسطينيين بشكل مباشر
دون اي ذريعه تذكر فيه او اسباب لم تشكل
اي خطوره على جنود الاحتلال
المباشره من المنزل الشهيد وفي لحظات
الوداع سمير ابو شماله شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]